all right we have a murder mystery to
talk about from director Ryan Johnson
director of brick Looper Knives Out
a couple other movies I'm forgetting and
before we get started civility says I
think the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by the ridge the
ridge Wallace the Sleek minimalist
alternative to the wallet holds up to 12
cards inside room for cash on the back
that's right that's a it's a stack of
ones
we all know where I'm going after this
video stop it comes in over 30 colors so
they're bound to have the style that
fits you and I said goodbye to my
keyring got the ridge key case holds up
to seven keys kind of like a pocket
knife for your keys and has a little
spot on the end for your car key if your
car keys aren't shaped like keys so this
is me organizing my pockets so click the
link below go to ridge.com Johns and
from now through December 22nd get up to
40 off and now we're gonna be like Vault
and get to it
[Music]
you remember Vault I'm not showing my
age don't worry I'm gonna show my age a
lot more in this review I'm coming into
this video with grumpy old man energy
sorry wish it was better but I gotta get
this review done today so this is the me
you get today so Glass Onion and knives
out mystery is a spin-off to knives out
I'd say spin off more than sequel I mean
it takes place in the same universe but
if you never saw Knives Out you will not
be lost with Glass Onion think the
relationship between the fugitive and
U.S Marshals Edward Norton plays this
eccentric billionaire in which he gets
all of his friends together every year
to play out a murder mystery you know
those fake murder mysteries that are fun
to do with groups but then someone dies
then that fake murder mystery becomes a
real murder mystery luckily they got
Benoit Blanc there now the cast in this
film I thought was great it's actually a
really packed cast Daniel Craig Janelle
Monae Edward Norton Kate Hudson Dave
Batista they're all standouts that's
only like half the cast but I gotta say
it seemed like forever and I was like so
this murder mystery thing is that gonna
happen I mean the Run time's around 2
hours 20 minutes so I guess by
comparison they were making good time
still felt like forever before we
started to get going what was like that
or when I can feel my grumpy old man
energy coming out like I said because I
see critics who are like man if you
loved the first knives out or wow wow
I'm like well I mean yeah it was
enjoyable
I didn't have a religious experience I
didn't find Jesus in the movie but yeah
it was enjoyable and I give that
positive to the cast I feel like Daniel
Craig and the rest of the cast in this
movie they're having so much fun you can
almost feel it through the screen
please a year from now don't tell me
that filming was a nightmare yeah that
would be a bummer but you know I forgot
to say this before this isn't a mystery
movie This is actually a mystery comedy
which could be fine Clues are mystery
comedy but it's a 2022 mystery comedy
which makes it a 2022 movie that has
comedy in it that's trying to actually
take itself seriously in Parts which
means the comedy is compromising the
tension in certain scenes I don't mean
to blame the MCU for everything but I do
call moments like that MCU humor because
it happens in the MCU now and I can't
help but think other movies out there go
hey what's the tip of the pyramid it's
okay the MCU the biggest box office
franchise on Earth well they're doing
that obviously they're doing something
right so let's do that do I wait on pins
and needles for the day when movies go
back to being dark dreary and drab as
[ __ ] well kind of I didn't hate that
those those are fine times the movie
does its part to massage you into the
fact that this is a ridiculous film
because Edward Norton's character his
house is this crazy extravagant castle
that no one would ever actually have
everything in there is just like you
have what is this Tech to the point of
being ridiculous this house is and so
that could do its part to massage you
into the fact that the characters are
every bit as
caricatured but it didn't really do the
whole job for me that was a big thing
that held this movie back I felt like
the characters didn't feel like
characters they felt like caricatures of
characters they felt like cartoons and
that Animaniacs kind of way you know
like when they'll have Michelangelo
Michelangelo in Animaniacs isn't like
Michelangelo but it's how Animaniacs
would portray Michelangelo in the same
way that's kind of how the characters
and the jobs they have in this movie are
portrayed exaggerated in such a way I'd
rather have some comedic moments with a
movie that is navigating with characters
that feel real maybe the world's
eccentric maybe the house is eccentric
but I can still get behind the
characters because they feel real they
don't feel like exaggeration in the end
to its core though I actually did enjoy
the film I know it feels like I'm
bitching about the movie a lot but I
don't mean to just got to address all
the things that's kind of what we're
here for right I thought the cast was
great the mystery was enjoyable I'm not
even talking about the murder mystery I
just thought the mystery among the
friends circle was actually a pretty fun
mystery also yeah that's right there's a
murder that's fun too the movie's fun
it's funny sometimes it's funny to its
detriment but I overall enjoyed myself
that is to say it's a pretty good time
no alcohol required keep in mind this
movie's a Netflix film it's coming to
theaters this week it's having a limited
run in theaters this week but it's
coming to Netflix I believe the
beginning of December I should really
know the date oh globally on Netflix
December 23rd Oh I thought it was
earlier than that okay so December 23rd
but I do think it's better suited for
Netflix there's something about sitting
in your couch eating whatever food you
want to stuff your face with rather than
the shitty overpriced concessions that
you're getting at a movie theater not
only can you sit through that two hour
20 minute movie just fine but you can
pause it if you want come back tomorrow
alright so Glass Onion have you seen it
what did you think about it what's your
favorite murder mystery out there or
mystery in general who done it whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]